(gentle etheric music)
Dr. Blackwelder's returning.
We're gonna have our third in our series on geriatrics.
And, Russell, I'll have you take it away, sir.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, sir.
This is my favorite geriatric lecture.
Things make more sense to me when I understand why.
This is kind of like the why lecture of geriatrics.
Why is it things affect older adults differently?
So we're gonna get into that,
and every time the Beers Criteria gets updated,
it's like Christmas for folks who practice geriatrics.
And it was updated a couple of years ago now.
So we'll tie into some of that.
Now, let's get into some of the problems first.
This is a little bit of an older slide
that I've been using and I inherited from somebody,
but the difference, these particular cardiovascular drugs,
who's getting studied, the ages that are in studies,
and then the ages of folks getting treatment.
So most folks in studies are younger, they're healthier,
but the medicines that we use are applied
to older adults, okay?
Now this is some newer data.
Who's in studies?
The light blue is folks older than 65, okay?
Oh, it gets even better.
The next slide is delightful, okay?
I can see your excitement.
Here it is even specific conditions.
It breaks it down, all these common things we do,
insomnia, heart failure,
AFib, osteoporosis, diabetes, okay?
So younger people in studies,
and then they're being applied to these new medications
to older adults who are on multiple medicines
and chronic conditions and all that.
Okay, so that's also the beauty of geriatrics
'cause it all comes down to the person in front of you,
and the art of medicine really matters.
And as family doctors, we're good at that.
We're good at the science,
but we're also really good at relationships
and finding out what our patient's goals are.
So here's our question.
Which of the following pharmacokinetic factors
changes the least with age?
The least.
Let's see how we did.
Oh, all right.
Okay.
Let's start over.
No, just kidding.
This is tough.
These are tough questions,
especially this late in the afternoon.
Actually, absorption changes the least
as people get older, okay?
Everything else changes pretty considerably.
That's why medications
affect older adults differently, okay?
And then it becomes even more complicated.
I mean, this is a really tough question
at this point in the afternoon.
You got an 80-year-old hypertensive woman switched
from atenolol to propranolol
'cause trying to kill two birds with one stone.
She's got a tremor.
A week later, she's more bradycardic, confused, despondent.
Most likely cause is which of the following?
Boom, look at that. (laughs)
Yeah, lipophilia of propranolol.
So even within certain classes of medicines,
they're gonna affect folks differently, okay?
You think older adults have more or less fat?
They lose muscle, they're gonna have more fat, okay?
Less protein, we'll get into this, okay?
So changes with aging.
I'm gonna be very open and honest with y'all.
I am 43 years old.
February is my birthday month.
When you reach your mid 30s,
naturally your creatinine clearance starts to decline, okay?
And that's gonna continue throughout your life.
Same thing with...
It really is remarkable the amount of muscle mass,
muscle explosiveness that we lose too
when we start to be 40 years old,
and that compounds every year.
That's why resistance training exercise are so important
to maintain independence, okay?
So absorption-minimally changed.
Distribution, we talk more fat, less muscle.
Metabolism over time, naturally, the liver shrinks.
There's less blood flow.
It's probably been a long time since we thought about this
since we're in medical school,
phase one and phase two metabolism.
I've been picking on the residents.
They're probably closer to this
and remember it better than the rest of us.
Phase one is affected more than phase two.
So medicines that go through phase one
are gonna be a bigger deal for older adults.
Got an 84 year old man, less alert, balance deteriorating.
He was taking five milligrams of diazepam twice a day
and agrees to stop.
One week later, he's no better.
Three weeks later, he's improved.
Why did this happen?
Withdrew the drug too quickly,
active drug metabolites, increased receptor sensitivity,
or (chuckles) patient didn't listen to you
and just kept on taking the medicine?
They were lying.
That never happens.
Yeah, yeah, very nice.
This gets into even within certain classes of medicines,
diazepam is gonna be more reliant
on that phase one metabolism as opposed to lorazepam,
which is more dependent on phase two.
So that would probably be a safer choice,
the lorazepam, if you're gonna use something, okay?
There are only two safe medicines in geriatrics.
I'll tell you.
Tylenol and Colace, and Colace doesn't work, okay?
(audience laughs)
Everything else is gonna have a risk to it, all right?
So diazepam would be a big no-no medicine.
A lot of questions, keep you all engaged.
Which one changes the most with age,
absorption, distribution, metabolism, elimination?
It's elimination.
That's the biggest factor,
that clearance of medications.
All back to that creatinine clearance decreasing with age.
Now, a lot of people, a common question I get
with this lecture is, which matters more,
GFR or creatinine clearance?
It depends.
I'm a family doctor, so I'm very simple.
It depends on what the medication was studied for, okay?
So you're gonna have to have your resource ready to go.
Some medicines are dosed based on creatinine clearance.
Some are based on GFR.
You gotta start being familiar with that.
We should get used
to calculating creatinine clearance though, okay?
Usually we get a BMP CMP
It calculates the GFR eGFR for us.
Creatinine clearance, we've gotta pull up on our phone
and our favorite calculator
and just plug in the numbers, okay?
Which one of these folks do you think
has a lower creatinine clearance?
Got a 50 year old woman, 150 pounds.
Creatinine comes back 2.2.
That's gonna catch our attention, right?
Or we got an 80 year old woman, 110 pounds.
Serum creatinine is 1.4.
We think, ah, you know, ah, you know what?
Maybe.
Maybe I gotta pay attention to that or not.
Depends on if it's late in the afternoon, okay?
Which one is worse?
It's gonna be that 80 year old.
Look at that.
All of a sudden they're below 30,
and that's a cutoff for a lot of medication changes, okay?
Because you take weight and age
into effect for the Cockroft-Gault calculation.
Do not memorize this equation, okay?
If that's on your exam, that's wrong.
(audience laughs)
Send them a letter and complain about it, okay?
You know, we've noticed this.
If this has happened to you before,
you get a BMP or a CMP on somebody
and the creatinine comes back, it's low,
or maybe it's even sometimes like too low to calculate,
you've seen that before?
Why does that happen?
(audience member chatters)
Where's creatinine come from?
Muscle, right?
If they're frail and older, they don't have enough muscle
to break down to get in the bloodstream
to really have a significant...
So we always overestimate the creatinine clearance.
And those of you who are in your mid 30s,
the decline has started.
80 year old on warfarin, INR 2.5.
Best explanation for increased bleeding risk
compared to a younger patient is,
difference in elimination, metabolism,
volume of distribution, or pharmacodynamic differences?
See, all these questions are hard.
We should do this lecture first thing in the morning
when you have coffee.
So let's get into this just in case these show up
on your exam, okay?
Pharmacokinetics, those are the elimination,
absorption, metabolism.
That's what the body does to the drug.
Pharmacodynamics, that's what the drug's gonna do
to the body.
The Coumadin, it's gonna increase bleeding risk, okay?
Elderly are at greater risk
because they're more likely
to have some of these bad events, okay?
So if you get these simple definition questions,
knock it out, get the question right,
then forget what they mean.
Just kidding, but get your question right.
AGS choosing wisely.
Don't prescribe a medicine without conducting a drug review.
We're all family doctors and we know this happens.
The patient goes to all these different kind of specialists
and gets started on all kind of things
that we might not even know about, okay?
Certain medicines might have been started
to treat the side effects of other medicines, right?
So make sure they're bringing in a med list,
family's bringing in a med list.
Your staff are really, really focusing on this.
Here's our resources, Beers Criteria, START/STOPP list.
You can plug this into your favorite search engine,
the Anticholinergic Burden Scale.
That's a nice tool because it will have point values
for different kind of different medicines
and how anticholinergic they are, which is nice.
For instance, paroxetine,
also known as Paxil, on the Blackwelder list of things
he will find his family medicine residents
if they ever start it on an older adult
because it's so highly anticholinergic.
I have gotten thank you notes from patients
who come to us in rehab.
They're there for a broken hip.
They're there visiting their daughter from Illinois
and they say, "No, no, no Blackwelder,
"I don't know you.
"I've been on paroxetine for 20 years and I do okay."
And I say, "You know, really, let's wean it
"while you're here.
"Let's get off of it and try it."
They finally buy in,
and I get a thank you note from 'em six months later.
And they say, "I didn't realize how much
"that was affecting me."
That's fun, okay?
So add that to the list.
Polypharmacy, five or more medications.
You all know this.
You're on more than that, more than four medicines,
you raise your risk of falling
and all kind of other bad outcomes.
So you can total up the Anticholinergic Burden Scale score,
and you might not be able to get people off everything,
but if you can decrease that total score,
you're doing patients really, really a big favor.
You can print this out and hand it to them.
Educate your staff about it,
and your staff is gonna like...
They're gonna love this stuff,
and they're gonna start talking to patients about it.
And then because we're family doctors
with relationships, over time,
we're gonna make a difference
and get people off some stuff.
Beers' pearls, first-generation antihistamines.
Make sure you ask what they're taking for sleep at night.
Hopefully it's nothing.
Oftentimes, it's fill in the blank PM. (laughs)
Please stop taking the Benadryl for sleep, okay?
Clonidine, anticholinergic.
Max dose of digoxin, 0.125 milligrams daily
in an older adult.
Benzos (growls) especially for sleep at night, why?
Same thing as drinking a glass of wine or a bottle of wine.
You're gonna go to sleep really fast, okay?
But you're not going to achieve that deep sleep
and REM that we need to restore memory
and our functioning, okay?
Sulfonylureas are now on the Beers Criteria,
TCAs, of course, and a question, PPIs.
PPIs, according to the Beers Criteria,
people shouldn't be on 'em for longer than eight weeks
unless there's a compelling indication
like Barrett's esophagus peptic ulcer disease.
They failed coming off of treatment, okay?
You got 75 year old urinary symptoms.
Creatinine clearance, less than 30.
Which antibiotic is contraindicated?
'Cause you did a good job plugging in creatinine clearance
before you prescribed the medication.
So now you know you shouldn't be doing it.
Yeah, that's pretty good.
The majority got nitrofurantoin, okay?
That's the answer, Macrobid.
I want to emphasize we'll hit on nitrofurantoin real quick.
I want you to hear me clearly.
It is okay for acute simple cystitis, okay,
if creatinine clearance is okay.
The risk if the creatinine clearance is less than 30 is
peripheral neuropathy and liver toxicity.
Those are gonna be the biggest risks, all right?
It is on my list for my learners
if you're gonna give somebody nitrofurantoin
on a daily chronic long-term prophylactic basis,
I will find them, okay?
The reason is 'cause of increased risk
of pulmonary fibrosis, okay?
I'm tired of having people come to me
and by the time I meet them for the first time,
they're already on hospice
'cause of their pulmonary fibrosis
because they've been on Macrobid for four years, okay?
So keep an eye out for that.
There's my other ones.
H2, it would be a good board question
if you had somebody in the hospital
and maybe they're in the ICU
and they're delirious.
When you're reviewing the med list,
make sure to pay attention to H2 blockers,
famotidine, ranitidine, okay?
Even simple medicines like that
increase the risk of delirium, okay?
There's my other ones.
You know, also, if you get somebody,
a good segue from the BPH talk,
an older adult and you want to treat their BPH
plus their hypertension,
alpha blocker might not be the best choice
if it's a peripheral one.
Of course, you're not gonna use tamsulosin
to treat blood pressure.
That's okay for BPH,
but terazosin, doxazosin and prazosin,
you know, those because the risk of orthostasis
is so great and fall risk, okay?
You might be better doing tamsulosin
plus something better with long-term data
for hypertension, okay,
if you're doing that.
The prescription errors, responsible five to 28%
of acute geriatric admissions, 4% of office visits,
a lot of hospital admissions.
Preaching to the choir on that.
Here we go, 88 year old sees you in clinic three days
into a viral illness, flu and COVID negative,
and trouble sleeping for the last two days.
Wife reports his cognition has decreased.
The patient has more difficulty urinating
and is reporting constipation.
Vitals are fine.
You should ask about what?
Yeah, over the counter medications, okay?
Big problem.
Make sure folks are telling you even the stuff
they're buying at the drug store that they're taking.
Now we got a nine 92 year old male,
regular diabetes follow up.
A1C is 6.9, hemoglobin 10.2, creatinine 0.9,
otherwise labs are okay.
Medications, metformin, aspirin, glipizide, empagliflozin.
Regarding his A1C, you counsel,
great job, keep it up,
emphasize importance of diet and exercise,
or D/C the jardiance, or D/C the glipizide?
Yeah, oh, there you go.
Wasn't 99%, but we're happy.
That's great.
Yeah, on the Beers Criteria now is to not do sulfonylureas
'cause of the risk of hypoglycemia, okay?
According to this, this is a tough thing
for all of us to wrap our heads around,
but really, you know, tight control ends up doing more harm
than good in older adults.
According to the choosing wisely for an older adult,
you really need to be somewhere in the seven and a half
to nine A1C goal, okay?
Where do you fall in there?
It depends on life expectancy, okay?
Now, in fairness, if I've got a 75 year old
and they're still going hiking in the mountains,
and, you know, I might try to be a little tighter than this,
but if I've got somebody with advanced COPD,
advanced heart failure, eight and a half is okay.
All based on life expectancy
because those complications we worry about,
they take so long to develop, okay,
when you're not controlling diabetes.
As opposed to controlling blood pressure and lipid,
that's usually time to benefit two to three years.
So there you go.
Life expectancy all comes down to that.
That's the art of geriatrics.
All right, I got an 89 year old hypertension, CAD,
history of right hip replacement.
Set up a visit to get a prophylactic antibiotic
prior to dental extraction.
What's the appropriate best course of action?
Yeah, and Dr. Vale hit on this a little bit too.
There's some resources if you wanna look into that
a little bit more from even the ADA.
Here's, you know, drugs impairing cognition, just a few.
Y'all know all this.
The right answer is not to do a muscle relaxer,
but if you were to do one,
the right answer in an older adult
would be methocarbamol or Robaxin.
The reason is because its half-life is the shortest.
So that's a good principle for prescribing.
If you're gonna choose something
within the class of medicines
and you're worried about side effects,
choose the one with the shortest half-life.
So rather than cyclobenzaprine,
methocarbamol would be a better choice
if you've gotta do it, okay?
Even simple things that we don't think much about,
ondansetron is a safer option than promethazine, okay?
If any of you work like in a rehab facility,
your administrator is gonna want you to do promethazine
'cause it's cheaper than Zofran,
but you're gonna put the patient at risk,
and you might end up saving resources long-term
by doing something safer, okay?
Sleep.
Sleep, sleep, sleep.
That Lancet article I'd mentioned earlier
about dementia prevention, they looked at sleep,
and it looks like, I mean, according to the data
and the meta-analyses they did,
kind of the key threshold for hours of sleep per night
to not raise your risk of dementia
is you need at least five hours, okay?
We'll see if that continues.
I'm surprised it's that low, honestly.
Here's what they said though, which is interesting.
If people were on medicine for sleep,
it didn't matter how long they slept,
you're still at risk.
So what do you do for sleep?
Always get this question too.
It's easier to answer what we don't do for sleep,
which is pretty much anything, okay?
You know, we do melatonin
if we can get away with that,
all those sleep hygiene, those type of things, lights out.
We gotta try stuff.
We gotta do better at that.
I mean, (chuckles) don't lay in bed doom scrolling,
all that kind of stuff, okay?
Y'all are gonna ask, what do you do for sleep?
I don't have a good answer for you
other than try melatonin,
and this is easier said than done, I know,
and it takes time.
Takes time.
Blood pressure JNC-8, recommended adults 60 and older.
Blood pressure goal, less than 150 over 90.
This came out about a decade ago, was pretty controversial.
And then 'cause it also came out about the same time
as the SPRINT trial,
which showed really, really tight blood pressure control
was beneficial for decreasing cardiovascular outcomes.
Of note, SPRINT trial excluded diabetics,
those with previous strokes,
institutionalized elderly, people with dementia.
So you missed a lot of people.
So what do you get to do?
Do you shoot for a higher or tighter?
And then we're back to life expectancy.
If you've got a pretty severely demented person
in long-term care and you try
to get their blood pressure control down to 110, 120,
they're gonna have bad outcomes, okay?
You're seeing an 80 year old
that has no other health problems
and they're talking about how much fun
they're having visiting family all over the country
and they're not having side effects,
it's reasonable to keep them cardiovascularly healthy, okay?
Maybe tighter control.
Pay attention to frailty syndrome.
That can help us sort out
who needs more aggressive treatment versus not, okay?
Three or more of those is frailty.
All right, 76 year old dementia, ED follow-up
after a compression fracture.
Now more confused, loose stools.
Temperature's 100.6.
Your exam reveals hyperreflexia and mild tremor.
Home meds are sertraline, trazodone, and atorvastatin.
Which medication did the ED give
that is likely causing these symptoms,
oxycodone, tramadol, calcitonin or ibuprofen?
Yeah, tramadol, serotonin syndrome, okay?
Which is the following to be proven
to be protective against dementia,
estrogen, vitamin D, educational attainment, or turmeric?
By being a physician and all that educational attainment,
that was well proven to help protect you
from developing dementia.
Keep it up.
(audience laughs)
I mentioned that The Lancet article.
Here's some kind of a summary slide.
The World Health Organization has good information
about dementia prevention too.
You know, we're doing a good job of controlling diabetes,
hyperlipidemia, all these cardiovascular risk factors.
When you're 40 year olds,
that's really, really helping them lower their risk
of dementia later on in life, okay?
And there you go.
Cholinesterase inhibitors, they have side effects,
minimally helpful.
AGS choosing wisely, don't do that
without checking on those side effects periodically.
It'd be a great board question of somebody coming in
on Aricept and their heart rates in the 50s or 40s,
and Aricept, donepezil could be the cause of it
with bradycardia.
Don't forget that.
Not always just your calcium channel blockers
and your beta blockers.
And there are my answers.
Thank you very much, Dr. Blackwelder.
(audience applauds)
(gentle etheric music)